I WAS ACTUALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS ONE, BUT OF COURSE I GOT MY
PERIOD TODAY ZBLI WANT A PERIOD
OPTION THAT'S CONVENIENT AND
DISCRETE SO I DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT LEAKS, ODORS OR
ANYTHING.
>> WHAT I'M AT WORK, I DON'T
HAVE TIME TO RUN BACK AND FORTH
TO THE BATHROOM.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO FORGET ALL
ABOUT IT.
>> NOW YOU CAN WITH PINX
UNDERWEAR.
YOU'LL BE COVERED ALL DAY LONG
NO MATTER WHAT.
AND THE ONLY PERSON WHO HAS TO
KNOW YOU'RE ON YOUR PERIOD IS
YOU.
>> NOW MY PERIOD IS MY LITTLE
SECRET.
OH, A DOG.
>> FINALLY, AN UNDERWEAR THAT'S
AS NATURAL AS YOU.
IT'S MADE OF ALL ORGANIC
MATERIALS.
>> I LOVE NOT HAVING TO BRING A
BAG OF SUPPLIES WHEREVER I GO.
>> I LOVE NOT HAVING TO THINK
ABOUT IT.
>> NOW I GET TO DO ME, AND PINX
DOES THE REST.
>> WOW, DOGS REALLY LOVE YOU.
>> YEAH.
I HAVE A CHEESE BURGER IN MY
POCKET.
>> WHAT?
>> EVERYONE IS DIFFERENT.
PINX HAS OPTIONS FOR EVERY LEVEL
.
>> I LOVE STINKS -- SORRY, PINX.
>> NO MORE HIDING, PLASTIC, AND
NO MORE STRESS.
YOU SHOULD FEEL BEAUTIFUL.
HUMAN, ATTRACTIVE.
NOW, YOU CAN WALK PROUD.
HAVE YOUR PERIOD THE WAY NATURE
INTENDED WITH PINX.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO FOR
DINNER?
>> I CAN'T HEAR YOU.
>> DO YOU WANT TO GET DINNER
OR --
>> I CANNOT HEAR YOU.
>> OH, MY GOD!
RUN!
THIS IS THE BEST IDEA WE GOT.